don lemon on cnn
i i if i think don lemon might be a
talking point slot machine i think we
might have just hit the jackpot
listen there are many good things about
political parties and many not so good
things about political parties but i
just don't believe in voting because
someone is a republican or someone as a
democrat i vote on what they what they
have done what they will do what their
records are and what they stand for so
having said that there is one political
party in this country that is working on
reality and that is a democratic party
but even in that they're not governing
very well at the moment they're not
performing the duty of being good
politicians in the moment they don't see
the urgency of what's happening across
the country with voting rights what's
happening
the urgency of of um what's happening
with the the big lie
this they are still operating on uh
thinking that oh everything is
normal
you know we've we've gotta play politics
as usual it's not politics as usual what
is happening on the right is not
politics as usual and what's happening
on the right is not right it's wrong
and they they should pay the
consequences for what they're doing to
our democracy the damage they're doing
to our democracy and the damage they're
doing to this republic it's not just
that what what don lemon said is not
true
it's that it's meaningless that's the
problem the meaninglessness
don lemon comes out on cnn
and he
goes on this rant about
the political parties
and partisanship and normal and how
we're not living in normal times and
republicans are a threat to our
democracy
and the i mean we can go through point
by point and we will very briefly but
my issue with it is not
it it's not his partisanship he's
obviously a democrat it's not his
ideology he's obviously a leftist
so much as his mindlessness i have
friends
who are liberal friends
friends of mine for many many years
family members
beloved family members
who will
who will do this sort of thing
i i it doesn't bother me if you
don't know anything about politics it
doesn't it doesn't by think bless it or
you if you can just sort of do your job
and
watch sports and hang out with your kids
and just have a nice time that's that's
great good for you no i don't think
people need to be in the nitty-gritty of
politics all the time but what does
bother me
is when people without doing any work or
any sort of research or giving any real
thought whatsoever to a political issue
mindlessly just spout off these kinds of
slogans that's a big problem that's a
far greater threat to our democracy
than any of this stuff
first thing don lemon says is look i
don't i don't like partisanship okay
parties have their place but i don't
just vote for someone because they're a
democrat okay i vote for the person not
the party the person
what does that mean what does that mean
lots of uncertainty out there in the
markets right now in our economy and our
whole political system which is why i
think a lot of people are interested in
investing in physical precious metals
specifically gold but you will say
michael but michael
it's very expensive to invest in
physical gold
calm down what if i told you you could
invest for 30 bucks a month michael you
liar don't call me a liar listen listen
up acre has developed this new system
you subscribe to their gold bars when
your gold stash reaches the price of
their gold bars you will discreetly get
acre gold physically at your home and
you can have it and you can enjoy it
they've also got 100 subscription to a 5
gram gold bar
i have really enjoyed investing in
physical precious metals and in acre
gold specifically go to
getacregold.com start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
that url because acre is giving away a
gold bar to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient and mention at get underscore
acre that's getacregold.com
knowles
i don't i don't vote for
the person i vote for
what the person is going to do and what
the person is going to do is informed by
how that person views the world and how
that person views the world is going to
align almost perfectly with a political
party
i vote for the person at the party means
i like the person's haircut i like the
way they talk i like the i i think that
person is attractive
really if you had to choose between the
two you should vote for the party not
the person
because at least the party tells you
something about the ideas what the
person thinks what they're to do the
person that's just
flattery it's just superficial but for
the person not the party so okay so
you're going to vote for a
under what circumstances done lemon
would you vote for a republican
probably never he's probably being
disingenuous but i guess he could say it
just makes him feel good to seem like
he's really open-minded but i guess he
would say votes for a republican when
the republican wants to do a bunch of
democrat things well then he's just
practically a democrat
okay then he goes on he says democrats
aren't paying attention to what the
republicans are doing with voting rights
what about with voting right it's just
such a vague slogan with voting rights
with with the big lie
with the big what is the big lie
don lemon doesn't even know what the
phrase the big lie means the big lie
which is how democrats describe
donald trump's perfectly reasonable
observation that there were some
strange shenanigans with the 2020
presidential election
uh the big lie
it was a phrase that it refers to the
nazis right this is what uh this is why
they're using that phrase to compare
republicans to nazis what they don't
realize is
hitler used the phrase the big lie
in
mein kampf
to accuse the jews of telling a lie
about a german general as pertained to
world war one so when when you accuse
someone of using the big lie you are
actually putting yourself in the place
of hitler and putting your opponents in
the place of the jews again a point lost
on people who don't
pay any attention to these things and
who are not thoughtful and who are not
particularly educated like don lemon
okay then he goes on this is what
they're doing to our democracy first of
all we don't live in a democracy we
don't the american government is not
supposed to be a democrat it's a it's a
form of democracy it involves
some democratic elements it includes
some non-democratic elements as well
and ironically the people most opposed
to our democracy at the moment seem to
be democrats who believe that laws on
for instance abortion should be made
from the judges that that laws on
coronavirus mandates should be pushed
from the executive agency that who
believe that
all these sorts of decisions that
marriage itself ought to be redefined
against the will of the people by
certain judges all of these sorts of
things
the only party
resembling an oligarchic party in the
united states would be the democratic
party
absolute
mind do not
do not do this yourself i don't need to
warn you
you're a thoughtful person
do not do not pair with these mindless
slogans it's very very embarrassing i'm
so glad that you enjoyed this video on
youtube i'm so glad youtube let me keep
this video up because sometimes i say
true things and then youtube doesn't
want me to say those true things so they
say that the true things are false
things and then they promote false
things and it's really frustrating if
you want to stop that kind of
preposterous dangerous anti-american
censorship i would strongly recommend
you go check out the audio version of
this podcast which is harder for the big
tech tyrants to censor you can get that
at the michael knowles show it's free
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your podcasts head
on over there before
some of these other joints try to censor
us entirely
[Music]
[Music]